does anyone know what identity means no  it's who you are right that's what it  means now who likes to pretend to be  things there's anything you like to  pretend to be  a ninja  that's a good one what about you  all right that's what this book is about  it's all about a boy who pretends to be  a walrus he identifies as a walrus and  his mom's a little silly she takes it  seriously and thinks he really is a  walrus that's silly isn't it you're  johnny the walrus till you change your  mind mommy says  but johnny's mom's phone said it's not  just pretend only a bigot would say that  how dare you offend all these people are  holding signs johnny is a real walrus  one sign says human walruses are real  walruses let johnny transition all these  people are saying you'll need to eat  worms and to put on gray makeup  [Music]  the worms give you whiskers the gray  blends you in the doctor says  and a simple procedure cuts feet into  fins